all right hello everybody let me just
adjust
my business here actually just go over
and what we're going to do is we're
going to like
last week we're going to talk about this
amazing uh
speed chess championship business that's
been going on
and um you know my whole life
well not my whole life but much of my
life
i've spent in let's say admiration
and befuddlement at hikaru nakamura's
blitz skills it's just been
you know for a long time now it's been a
thing hard to understand
and it's almost like uh
it's almost like the kid i might
when i say a kid i mean he's obviously a
little older now but i knew him when he
was a kid
didn't ever even think like it was you
know like i do a lot of chess teaching
and you know part of the drama as a
chess teacher
especially when you're teaching young
talented kids is just to get him to slow
down
you know and that is nothing as a
teacher it has nothing to do with your
own chess skills it has to do with
you know tricks and the how to that mind
how do you get them to slow down and a
lot of times you can and then they
oftentimes become very strong players
and then the thing with the cargo right
is the kid never slowed down
as far as i can tell and sometimes i
think he plays
better when he plays blitzchess and he
plays real chess
he did learn to slow it down a little
bit
at least compete at the highest levels
but it was always clear that the he was
going to be either
the very best at blitz or you know
second or third best templates
and um i've never understood that where
that came from obviously
you know he we you know in the chess
world we thought he was misspending his
youth and talent by playing blitz games
like
just 24 7 on the old icc
uh and somehow that did work for him
it's
you know it's unimaginable still to me
anyways today
what are we gonna do oh i blew it over
here guys hold on
um i just it's been a long day i got
done with
a um another one where you guys can
watch that was my grandmaster's choice
and so i'm just gonna do a little title
here
naca beats
so you can see my vast professionalism
uh recently i was referred to as a
as a tech grandpa and i'm starting to
just own it i'm not very good with the
technology
you know i'm okay with it i'm just i'm
just learning to embrace it
in any case so what i'd like to do today
is just review this semi-final that went
down
between hikaru and wesley last week i
looked at hikaru's amazing
just spanking of fedo safe and then
uh what we did last time was
we looked at the games that were the
five
five games by five five i just mean uh
excuse me five one i'm gonna ruin my
business here again
um let me go down here actually you can
probably see it here
uh so you get five one three one and one
one
you can't see it that well i'm terrible
as a tech grandpa anyways
what we're going to be covering today is
the five
one portion of this
event and look at that i already screwed
up the thing again
so we're gonna be looking at the five
one portion of things
and tech granville's really bad at this
stuff okay you know i
i'm well i need to move the screen
sometimes it's just
you don't even want to know about my
technical problems it is we're going to
look at the 5-1
and as for for my own self what i'm
interested in
like with ferisav is to see how
naka does it and this match was much
closer
ended up being decided by one point
and um i guess naka's now the favorite
and what it's so weird what's going on
with naka now right he's turned into
a celebrity on twitch people are loving
that dude and why it's because
he's the one person there's maybe more
but he's the one who does it the best
where
he can talk and beat people down at the
same time
and that's what i mean i don't think he
was ever thinking he was always just
making instant decisions
and uh right so befuddlement and part of
the
tonight's uh inquiry is for jesse to
understand and maybe explain
how he's doing it doubtful i'll be able
to explain it but i'm really gonna try
so we're just gonna go through these
games
in order the five one games and see
how it all went down so let's just start
with the first one
this is a draw and let's see how it went
okay yeah this is an ancient variation
let's just say that's a dirty trick with
bishop b7 if 95
queen a5 wins instantly
and okay let's say that was clever
and maybe white has well this typical
rui lopez position
ma drawish now one thing we'll say about
so
is his e4 e5 is just amazing
um i guess in a lot of ways
it's kind of like i've never played e4
e5 but in recent years it's like just
been a rock
and there's there's more than one way to
do it you know you got the
classical roy lopez systems you got the
marshall gambit you got the berlin
defense
you know loads loads of stuff
and and he's one of the best
he's not even fearing knight g5
not at all afraid of it
all right now this is just gonna peter
out i guess right
bishop h6 holy moly look at that
oh it's got a little spicy here oh
hecaro you want a pawn bro
so the problem though is the bishop on
a4 is pinned
right here and the pawn is in danger
so maybe in fact
maybe like wesley saw this
holy moly
wow that was impressive the knight on g3
is terrible
oh yeah that what a great game
and then they're gonna make a draw i
guess wow
very high level game and so if we go
back
like one of my questions is let's go
back to that bishop h6 moment
you know
i don't understand these rui positions
uh
one of the things actually i i just
think i was i would always be terrible
at them too that they're so
fast and loose and there's so much going
on like this bishop h6 move
and you know then if you do win it it's
going to be in a technical ending
and this is this is uh
so you got to believe in this especially
because the knight on h6 is so
terrible so like even if you ate crow
and played rook d1 bishop b4 bishop b3
i'd still believe white's
maybe a little better you know
okay so interesting let's look at game
two
i wanna i'm going fast kind of
deliberately i just want to get a sense
oh my god that i hope they don't e4e5 us
the whole time here
okay so you know
this is all carlson's fault by the way
you know
basically mickey adams in the 90s
shut down the traditional rui with
the marshall and since then
we've all just been playing this magnus
carlson small ball
with c3 d3
and basically white is
you know i think just equal which means
you know this is the opening really
to play if you're if you're black
because it's look at this position
your pieces are all open you have
chances for counter play
what could possibly go wrong right yeah
in this position
what i'd rather be black right i'd
rather be black in this one
that's just a clever move that's
obviously a gm move i guess because d
e i mean what isn't black
isn't black just better here
nice move nice move a car rook a6
defending any garbage on f6
uh developing the bishop on c8 where it
stands that's
that's just good chess okay
also good chess oh
and now we're going to peter to draw so
look actually that was amazing
uh i missed it too in this position he
probably felt he was doing phantasmal
and uh in fact knight d5 is a big
problem
and if like bishop b6 i maybe we should
do bishop b6 actually
with the intention of bishop takes e6
fe6 just so that we can keep it's not
going to be an advantage though
it's not going to be an advantage um
so that was kind of a cool defensive
save from so because
honestly like like i said it just looks
like after d5 were better
and so sacks the pawn knight on e3
blockades everything
natural and now
right if you play bishop b6 you're going
to lose the f5 square
and with a5 it carves i mean it's genius
level he's intending uh
this c5 move
and then i think it's all over for the
initiative here
very impressive game you know let's just
say i mean
yeah there's this i'm i'm reading about
fisher now i am i am john donaldson's
new book
and fisher was especially when he was
like late teens
talking smack and talking smack to
everybody
and you know especially saying things
like you could take down
any woman player giving her night odds
and stuff and
he might have been able to do and one of
the things that i wonder is like
i guess icaru could beat me with you
know a couple minutes on his clock
i i don't know why i would doubt that
even though i've done well with him in
classical chess
part of it is i really think the kid
some people are going to be
offended i call him a kid but i think he
i think he
doesn't think he just plays these moves
instantly man
that's my and it befuddles me like i
said
all right let's go to round three
okay so this one wesley wins we're gonna
have an e4 e5 extravaganza here tonight
uh
okay
looks pleasant for black yeah but you
know these positions
well okay
at least white has to come up with a
move here like you can't do bishop d2
because of d e
so there'd be like maybe just play h3
right okay knight of five
really fascinating
so my gut would be that
it's i guess roughly equal but the um
white of course with the bishop has
dreams
yeah such as
yeah this is all the fisher style here
just hang out
uh and bishop h6 was not possible
because of knight h5
and this move is a dirty trick d4
so you cannot do cd ed bishop f4 because
of knight h5
and in general d4 is a bad move
uh but some
because you're transferring to like a
king's indian
setup where things are gone wrong for
black
but in this situation
the black pawn chain on c6 b5 a4
is doing a lot in particular preventing
the bishop on c2
from coming out so this is a nice
paradoxical decision
right anytime you take we're just saying
that the bishop on c7 is going to be
loosed
oh i bet carl
might have missed that
okay really interesting so um
white needs to play bishop b1 to a2
can he do it
he says no i can't um
my my sense he says he should just do it
man you just play bishop b1a2
even if you lost a pawn it doesn't
matter you gotta fix your bishop dude
you gotta fix your bishop
and king h1 is some kind of dream about
playing f4
which is really hard to believe
yeah oh yeah i don't like this
i don't like i think these dreams are
dangerous for his health
oh now we're gonna get the e5 square oh
thank you very much
so now maybe i'm missing something as to
why you
cannot like obviously white's you know a
little bit of pressure but
king h1 trying to play for f4
really doesn't seem right to me um maybe
there's something
just tactically wrong with bishop b1 a2
but especially in a blitz game like
fix that pawn you might live you know
you might live so this just looks
like either lost or clearly worse i
would say
all right there then now the bishop
can't come because our rook went away
that's cold ouch
ouch that's kind of good night right
there
okay so wesley draws first blood in
round three
plus one at this point in the match
and now wesley wins again
wesley of course won the skilling open
before look at that move ruggy one man
all right wesley here we go
it's so amazing to me these newfangled
moves against
the night or this one i'm sure has been
played many times before i'm no expert
on this business
but um i'll tell you a funny story
i do a show with i am kostya kavutsky
and um you know nowadays
in this position so many weird moves are
played
a3 h3 uh
this is something like rook g1 right and
even knight b3 totally bizarre to me
um and
back in the day the feeling was that if
you were gonna
that you had to go kill black and so the
standard variation was always bishop g5
but you could also play bishop e2
or bishop c4 like these aggressive
developing moves
anyway so we're doing this show and i
was like oh yeah
back in the fischer days we would never
play a move like h3
and then costa caught me and it was like
fisher played
h3 against night or himself anyways i
bring it up because rook g1
is very similar to the h3 idea to play
g4 kerus attack style kick the knight
from f6 and gain some space and
hopefully that hope then that that space
leads to
a attack
on the king side there it comes
already you know dangerous
just brutal it's just so in your face
yeah
now i'm assuming that black is still
totally fine but of course this is
pretty spicy
now black had other options of course
and
the obvious question is why not
play hg and free that rook
i admire the way wesley did this because
we're just going to leave our king there
for a while and then see what happens
next even a move like g6 honestly maybe
it's even theory but
still you're just like going to wait and
see how he responds
and i guess the notion with this
will be carl was saying look i want to
just castle
and then all my rook will have the f
file okay so i
i think i understand that
right
now was that really necessary
i feel like in the olden days with
fisher he always wanted to play knight
c4
and maybe there's something dramatically
wrong with that
but with knight b3
i think it's a big deal that we give
white really the light squares in
particular c4
okay
maybe he missed that move
and now we just have the light squares
galore okay
so now i think we gotta say why it is
something like clearly better
yep old school
old school
dang just no remorse
um that's see this is an example
where these guys
are playing moves
in blitz games that are probably higher
level
than your common common loser like
myself
like for example in this position
if i'm white i would be worried that
he is going to survive with a move
like queen g7
and i'm not looking at the score so i
don't know exactly what he did but i'm
just telling you my
instant thoughts and definitely if i was
playing a blitz game i'd be like oh
aren't i gonna lose this after queen g7
so i'm missing something
yeah i don't get it dude okay let's
let's see what happened queen g7
all right pause pause what did wesley
find here
to hurt him
queen h1
maybe the queen h1
oh maybe
you could do okay this is interesting
if you do queen h1
maybe the guy can get away with rook g6
because there's bishop g5
check at the end
and on queen h5 i'm not sure what the
threat is you know
let's see what happens queen h3
okay if if some kind of rook f2 queen e6
is going to win the house
dude this is not clear who knows what's
happening i was saying let me just go
back a second
just in general i want to say that
white is doing fantastic here
and the black really doesn't have any
counter play
and so this decision to play bishop h6
probably just intuitive
but then bishop d8 and honestly it looks
like a car was on top
d5 i don't think was necessary
but it looks alright
cold-blooded okay
so that was a cool tactic so if you
imagine queen h7 gh
king takes rook h3
and then you gotta play rook h6 and then
i'm gonna win the bishop on f2
if takes takes gh king h8 then rook g8
is gonna win
but okay you just sidesteps
really unclear that doesn't look right
thank you for the pawn what
what are you doing bro
man pretty exciting stuff my friends
so you know when we look back in this
match hikaru uh
did not have a great start here
did not have a great start all right so
now we're gonna do nakamura's revenge
this is game number
five game number five
all right
all these little piddly carlson moves
man
and these positions do just great for
black
you know like he has so many choices of
how to play these things
now maybe he's gonna regret this kind of
thing
[Music]
nice
so let's just say the obvious thing um
wesley's queen can't
partake in the attack on the white king
so really if karu can open the g-file
he's going to win it seems hard to stop
him
and that's a sad concession because now
the work can just go
back now here's the interesting qual for
me it's an interesting question
what is the actual is gf
i guess he could have also yeah
rook g1 might be a you know once you
play bishop g4 though
then white again has the full light
squares
nice move
i think on a b dudes just going to hang
out on the light squares play king b1
does it anyway thank you very
much oh oh oh that was cold
that was cold so now with knight f4
hikaru has gh
that's really nasty
now i think he's now i think it's gone
it's got to be gone now
um no that's it
beautiful game from macaro
wow like i said
as a blitz player maybe maybe none
better
maybe none better all right
you know so funny i think uh hicaro
always resented
uh fabi for taking the limelight from
him
in u.s chess and he always you know his
his little nibble on bobby was that he
couldn't
play rapid or blitz that well it's
definitely true not on naka's level with
that kind of stuff all right here we go
next round
so carl's just like yeah i can the thing
about blitz right is you can get a
slightly worse position
this position by the way is hundreds of
years old they analyzed this
to death back in the day and like
right maybe white has a small edge here
actually i bet it's the kind of thing
the computer will say
that uh white is much better oh here we
go
uh-oh
yeah no problems for naca here
castles he ate
nothing nothing doing
just nothing at all
thank you very much
let's trade everything off
oh he has to be careful not to become
worse here
yeah all right let's end that one that
one's going to a draw
okay next one and now it's like with
three rounds left naka's down a point
and he's going to win the next two i'm
just going to telegraph that to you all
this next two
oh my god all this weird theory d5 it
doesn't look right to me
it's obviously some theoretical move but
it does not look right to me
the obvious question being 95 and
there's some
something something there's some kind of
something something after 95.
naka didn't even bite an a5 that's some
highfalutin chest my friend
i don't know what you're doing over
there with a5 i don't have a clue
i guess the claim is just like if you
take my knight
and take on e5 i'm going to have
abstract positional compensation in the
form of the bishops
interesting
one kind of cool thing actually that
hikaru doesn't bite like maybe the
computer would want to bite but
the knight on c6 is black's terrible
piece
and the bishop is beautiful on b5 so you
know
i don't want to do it he's just going to
play b4 and get a nice position
oh that's see that's smooth positional
style
oh yeah now white's a little bit better
very impressive uh positional play
positional play amazing okay let's check
this out
oh smooth okay more smoothness
okay interesting decision
so that we take that way
very nice transformation of the position
like i said you guys this guy he's
playing a
blitz at a level you know if you saw
this in some
gm game you'd be like oh this is really
interesting what he's doing
and i think we gotta say that black is
in clear
trouble now
this wasn't tactics this was like hikaru
doing some positional jujitsu
ouch
nice
oh it's old school yep
this looks like some ancient game from
1930 where they're just dominating
yep thank you very much
i get i mean yeah rusty's just playing
for tricks now right
very smooth very smooth
very smooth oh
ah that's not gonna work buddy
dang what
what
so this is this is next level
if knight d5
rook c8 king f8 there's bishop c5 now
it's not over it could go knight d5
rook c8 knight f6 but the problem is the
pawn on h4 is also toast
so the domination is actually kind of
real here
and my bishop is amazing
wow so caro at least it feels
like he lost control in here
and maybe it was even on this move
but despite the fact that he lost
seemingly control
his structure is so much better
um and
maybe it's already gone man maybe it's
already gone
all right yeah
right okay so we're going to see
if accaro can convert
in this kind of hectic i'm sure it was a
time scramble
man it might actually be gone here
thank you very much that's game
and he resigned he resigned maybe he
lost on time
maybe that show him that might be
showing too much respect to resign right
there my friends
interesting okay let's do another one
so wesley started losing his mind here
and this is the next one he loses
and it was this where you know they went
even from here on out because they go to
quicker and quicker time controls
so carl loves this thing
and let me just say something dogmatic
you spend some time you obviously invest
the tempo in knight d4
but c3 no longer dominates the knight on
c6
and the bishop on d4 gets out of dodge
right
just moving back to b6 is a bonus in
itself
both these guys love their a5 move
in my sense now you know actually when i
was a kid
these h6 g5 things they were kind of
like frowned on a little bit like you're
weakening your structure
but now it's so common and
in a lot of ways it's reminiscent of the
cava blanca winter game or winter cabin
block a couple of black was black where
the bishop on g3 doesn't get out
there it's totally entombed because
there's a the pawn on g2 is on f3
there's no way to get out but it's still
a case where the bishop
is poor over there and so right i think
bishop g5
is questionable from
wesley
yes is not the position you want against
naca
nope i guess knight h5 i'm gonna guess
was also
a move for him
dang
so now bishop d2 with the intention of
bishop g5
but now that dream is gone because the
knight's in the way oh
okay right so white now needs magic if
he's going to save this thing
oh was that is that the dream that we
were looking for
boom boom boom boom
fascinating okay so on rookie 2 what's
going to happen
there's no something terrible happens on
rookie 2.
and i think the answer wow this is
actually a very interesting position
the answer is on rookie 2 black's
i'm actually i'm not even 100 i was
going to say
rookie 2 maybe rook 8 but maybe just
king f1
this is this is what i'm talking about
this is like next level tactics here
so let's just take stock
white is up a pawn his king
is in the bucket i just made that term
up he's in the bucket
on g1
and wesley basically believes white
and takes on f4
but what would have happened on rookie
two
maybe it's actually i think it is it's
as simple as this
we go snip snop knight f4 to dominate
the bishop on b3
and then next move we play rook e8 and
it's actually
actually super unpleasant very
instructive
beautiful really okay
amazing
now i'm sure you turn the computer on
the computer would find all kinds of
other things but
wesley of course was banking on this
e-file stuff
you know actually let's just go back and
appreciate this for a second so
hikaru has a great position
and f5 is the maximalist
move to put white out of his misery
and he's to play it in five minutes i'm
gonna guess he already saw
that bishop f4 move
right because what else is white gonna
do
our king is much better much better
i'm wondering if i got this wrong too
because
in this position let's say the obvious
black could have taken on e6
in which case we are going to do
something i assume
there's more than one move here
bishop g5 is a move maybe just bishop g5
and then you know we're dreaming of
we're dreaming of a white christmas uh
we're dreaming of
all kinds of things with taking on h4
and you know the two bishops
i still kind of think black might be
better there
maybe a car will miss rook e5 because i
don't want to play rook f8
uh-huh
wow we're saying that the
we're still golden
thank you very much right so the
white king is so bad here
nice move nice move
gotta assume this is now lost oh and he
resigns
because g2 is going
honestly that was massive massive skill
i mean if you saw that yeah
that's a great example of a beautiful
blitz game by
carl if you saw that uh
if i play if anyone played that on a
long time
you know time control game you got to be
proud of that one
total total knockout man
total knockout very impressive
all right let's let's dwell on this one
let's dwell on this one because this one
was a masterpiece
and i gotta say i you know i enjoy
playing blitz
it's kind of a recreational thing for me
i don't take it too seriously
but blitz has become
the new the new thing especially in
covid times
because without over the board
play we're going to be online and online
play is kind of
by nature a fast format so people are
getting more and more into it
and the car was out there streaming like
a madman
and okay we're just going to get a
position and
wesley's going to do this kind of odd
night dance
and a5 is a great move
and bishop g5
i mean in hindsight doesn't look good
maybe either
bishop c2 bishop c2 might actually
have a problem with the knight e4 or
just 93.
and i'll say with the quality and he
wants more but this
that wasn't good by wesley even i can
see that
you're just kidding you're going to get
hurt here and it happens pretty fast
i think knight h5 here would also be
like the uh
the weak gm might myself would probably
play knight h5 here i think gotta be
better for
for black but akara's just gonna
push it you know that's a great maneuver
because now
the knight is blocking the bishop and
the bishop wanted to be
a pain on on g5
and this one like i'm going to say this
is technically lost
for white just because the king's so bad
the center's out of control
we got weaknesses no one's looking good
um but to finish it let's check it out
knight h5
and now it's all pretty forcing if you
let my knight land on f4 it's not going
to be pretty i'll sack on h3
soon and then the maximalist move man
dang
now let me just say so for my weak
minded chest
i would have felt a little bit like
maybe i'd
you know i was winning before and maybe
i feel like now i've lost the threat a
little bit
so especially if i got to play a move
that feels a little bit passive
like that okay
first question there might be other
questions too
but couldn't dude have played
rook ae1 here
wasn't that a better way of doing
business
ae1 seems like
it's at least more testing
i'm seeing some weird things but
that's not clear it's not as clear to me
and one of the things i'll say about
acaro is a lot of times i've seen him in
analysis and
end games too and he'll just be like oh
yeah that's winning now a lot of times
he just says stuff
and it's just like dude you're talking
you're just talking
but um sometimes it's like oh yeah he
actually understands an intuitive level
why this is a terrible thing
i'm just going to stare at a second it's
been a long day let's just see here
do i understand this thing i do not have
the computer turned on
i'm not interested right now in the
computer's evaluation because i just
want to see like
what do i see now rook d1 makes sense
too because you're denying knight d3 and
you're saying okay if you take on e5
buddy
then at least my d file be open
um i don't yeah i don't want to trade
off both rooks
i really don't
this week gm doesn't see it dude this
week gm does not see it
it's so hard to move the knight because
of the pawn on d5
you still okay you could still believe
in black because the king the white king
is so
so terrible but it's just hard to see
how he makes progress
i'm gonna go back okay i'm not gonna
even turn the computer on
but i'm gonna go back and say this
probably was
incorrect that ricardo let all this
happen
probably at the
very least i thought he was winning
before and after rook
ae1 i don't have any clarity of what's
going on
i turned off my on my chest 24
i think i turned off i turned off my
computer
i turned it off uh could i all right
i'll show the computer analysis let's
see
what does it say yeah it says white's
better my friend
says white's better so at least i was
correct on that and rook ae1 is the only
move after which white is better
okay turn it off buddy so very
i mean it's still a beautiful game it
doesn't change anything we're talking
about a game that was played with
pro you know i've been talking about it
longer now
than the time it took to play the thing
so beautiful match by a car that was one
more game is drawn
uh i'll scroll down here for a little
bit just to show you this
epic uh thing here
13 and a half to
12 and a half so it came down to a point
so that point in the first
round of five plus one decided at all so
this was a semifinal
and uh i assume coming up man coming up
we're gonna get
the final which i think is gonna be uh
tomorrow is mvl versus carlson i think
that's the other semifinal
probably it's gonna be carlson and naca
going ahead
all right everybody i enjoyed it a lot
this is uh
i'm not a blitz chess expert i'm
terrible at it
but i am trying i'm making an effort to
respect it as an art form
and i've been watching hikaru do his
thing now
for many years all right everybody bye
bye